hey Luke and Jacob here with the outdoor
boys YouTube channel and want to give
you a chance to meet the newest addition
to the outdoor boys YouTube channel
check out this sweet little guy look at
that yeah he is a sweet little guy he
was born today about two hours ago
weighs 7 pounds 6 ounces is 20 and a
half inches long and as healthy as any
parent could ask for and mom's doing
great as well and he is just absolutely
adorable
no surprise there he has excellent
excellent genes and yeah he is a great
great little guy and he will be going
fishing with me in no time let's give
you some money shots there look at that
yeah just just a lovely little guy look
at him and he's a good boy too long if
you keep him warm eats just not so fussy
he's had a rough day and he's just
taking it so well he is a cutie there's
the money shot right there look at that
yeah he's just doing really well so any
rate well not to worry guys I've
stockpiled some some great videos for
you I'll be posting some videos I did
and I posted him tomorrow so there
should be no interruption of service
somebody was asking about names his name
is Jacob David Nichols
so nice sturdy name you know Prince
blanket was already taken so you know we
had to find something else
uh yeah he is a cute little guy
yeah and if you would like to see a
picture of the 550 paracord blanket i
crocheted for him you can go to the
outdoor boy's Facebook page and see that
post and you're right look at that but
uh he is a good little boy and his
brothers are so excited to see Tommy and
Nathan are with Grandma and Grandpa and
thank you David thank you very much
thank you
and yeah so Grandma and Grandpa are at
home with Nathan and Tommy and they'll
get to meet their brother tomorrow it's
a little late tonight they should be in
bed in the sleep by now also I did a
little video log so I took a take a
bunch of video kept it g-rated no health
ed class videos for me but kept it G
rated no I'll be posting a detailed
little video log especially with the
boys reactions to their new their new
brother mom is doing great it was she's
a champ this is her third boy and this
was probably the best easiest delivery
so so far
yeah Beck is doing really well she's
doing really well we're just lucky mama
and baby are just couldn't have gone any
better
yeah yeah David just Samia shoot me an
email or message me on Facebook with
your address I'll be happy to send you a
sticker anybody who does a super chat
and donates of course I'll send you guys
stickers I'm glad to do it
thank you so any rate I'd uh it's just a
sweet little guy
so just to give you guys some updates
and what's coming up in the channel I've
got an awesome axe restoration video
that's coming up an awesome axe
restoration video that I'm going to be
posting tomorrow morning and I've got a
bunch of axe restoration projects coming
up some of them are really cool
I'm very - of nearly cut my tip of my
pinky off with one of them and so that
video should be coming I also doing some
paracord not videos or show you how to
make things out of paracord like
backpacks and water bottle holders and
things like that and I've got a tent I
can't I know a lot of people wanted to
see we did this we did a survey recently
and a lot of people want to see we're
camping videos well I've got about a
half a dozen tents and I'm gonna do a
big tent camping tent review video
series show you guys some reviews here's
and I've got an awesome survival kit
bug-out kit axe hack thing I'm going to
show you we're gonna take an axe and
make it into an awesome survival bug-out
kit so I've got some some cool things
coming down the way that I think you
guys will really like some more
blacksmithing videos - ya know I'm gonna
be spending a lot more time on the
outdoor boy's YouTube channel and
catsuit carp just because it's easy to
do projects in the driveway with
[Music]
sorry buddy it's kind of the family
business you know how it is that is that
is pretty sweet so for those of you guys
just tuning in this is Jacob newest
member of the outdoor boys and he was
born about two hours ago so welcome to
the world little Jacob mommy and baby
are just as healthy and as perfect as
can be seven pounds six ounces 20 and a
half inches not a PB but pretty good you
know I think Nathan had a beat just a
little bit but hopefully it's the only
time Nathan will beat them so any rate a
we're we are pretty jest what a sweet
little guy any rate still a keeper
absolutely so we are pretty thank you
very much Brian
yeah shoot me your address on Facebook
Messenger and I'll be happy to send you
some cats and car bumper stickers so
thanks for the donation any rate hey
guys I'm going to keep this nice and
short so uh I don't hog the baby all to
myself and no and yeah look at that you
just drink it in folks that is a cute
baby yeah all right so lots of great
videos to come guys also I recently on
our Spreadshirt account I put a link in
there our video descriptions if you want
to get an outdoor boys t-shirt we're now
selling them so check that out we got
some new gear but in air you guys I'm
gonna I want to spend some time with my
brand-new baby boy so you guys have a
great day and I'll be posting a great
video tomorrow morning so make sure to
tune in thanks guys
you